[Music]  last week cable provider Comcast  announced that it was buying Time Warner  Cable for forty five billion dollars  yeah now the deal if it happens would  combine two of the largest cable  companies in the United States to form  one massive conglomerate then a  corporate merger this large is a very  complex legal and financial deal how do  they do it Andy Donen they did it with  Thompson's corporate merger leader  slicking the tracks for smooth company  mergers since 1989  Thompson's merger loop you'll barely  feel it thanks Andy  by the way Andy where did you get that  big tube from Dell COEs House of giant  prize telcos if it's big it's funny  [Applause]